Visual Studio code is our cross-platform
lightweight open-source development
environment and you can come here to
code die Visual Studio comm there's a
big green button you can just download
it right away it's about 50 Meg download
sets up and installs in under a minute
not something you see from Microsoft
every every day but I'm not gonna
install a stable build I've got
something called the insiders build
installed on my machine already now the
insiders build is the same build that we
use to develop the S code it ships every
single night and what's great about it
is basically the next day you have
access to new features and bug fixes
literally the same ones that we do so
we're gonna use that that build for this
demo today so the first thing since I'm
in my tool I want to customize it to
work and feel the way that I
excuse-me work and so right away I'm
going to change the theme to work for me
you can see built-in we have a bunch of
light and dark themes that you can you
can pick from some nice ones there's a
red one Scott would probably like that
one goes along with this shirt
but what we're gonna do is we're gonna
come down here that you can install
additional color themes and we're gonna
go out to the marketplace where the
community has literally contributed
hundreds and hundreds of themes that you
can go and pick from and one of the cool
ones that I like recently is one by a
guy named West boss and I'm gonna click
on install it's called cobalt 2 and you
get a nice little preview down here it's
pretty cool and it's already installed
all I have to do is click on reload and
we'll restart the tool we'll go back the
color theme and you can see I can set it
to Cobalt right so now we've got a nice
theme that we can start to work with ok
so now that we've customized the
environment I want to bring up some code
and start working on that I'm going to
click on this web folder that I've been
working on and right away what we see is
we get a prompt from the tool because
the workspace says hey you know I've got
a set of extensions that if you install
those extensions you're gonna have a
great experience to Belling this
particular application and so what it
recommends to us is this thing called
the node pack for Azure and it's
installing it right away but what it is
is a collection of really cool
extensions for developing node
applications against adjure it helps you
get started very quickly apps service
functions cosmos TVs got talked about
docker that's already installed I can
just click on reload and now we're ready
to go and start programming our
application so I'm gonna bring up some
code now a pas and a couple things about
this
first off I should say one of the great
things that vias co does it brings a
great editing experience the great
editing experience is traditional from
Microsoft and Visual Studio across
platform so one of the cool things that
I can do I love doing this if I want to
go and change a few lines of code here I
hate using let if I can use a Const I
use a Const so I can select that I can
press command D and I'm just going to go
set a number of cursors excuse me across
all those lines and I can change those
to Kant's berry very quickly so a very
rich editing experience out-of-the-box
with just plain JavaScript I get
intellisense against my objects that I'm
using because it's driven by the
typescript compiler in the background
which can figure out a whole bunch of
stuff about my plain JavaScript you
don't have to use typescript but we use
it to give you a better richer
development experience so great editing
right out of the box so let's go and
we're going to run this application I'm
going to press f5 and what's gonna
happen is node is gonna start up on this
machine you can see now the app is
listening on port 3,000 go back over to
the browser just go to localhost 3,000
and what's going to happen is our app
will come up here inside the browser and
this is a smart hotel 360 application
let me just take a second and explain
what smart hotel 360 is it's a
fictitious company worldwide chain of
hotels and it's really trying to
highlight the future of connected travel
and throughout this keynote this morning
you're going to see applications and
demos all based on the hotel 360
application so in this case what we've
got is a map and we can see different
hotels that are part of the chain and I
can click on them and I can see hey you
know what the sentiment for the Platinum
Hotel not very good we could delve into
that later but the bigger problem is in
this application this chart on the
left-hand side though it doesn't exist
there should be one there so we want to
go and figure out how we can get this to
show up so I'm gonna go back over to BS
code and remember the app is still
running I haven't stopped the debugger I
can put a breakpoint here on line 19 and
if i refresh the page we're gonna end up
breaking back in our running application
on our machine so awesome the second
great thing about BS code it has a great
lightweight debugger built right in and
I can do everything that you expect I
can step over step into multi-line
statements I can hover over and see what
variables are I can set another
breakpoint and
I can just press run and we'll run all
the way down here and we get down to the
bottom where we're rendering this page I
can drill in I get a hover tip I can see
that I've got basically a bunch of
undefined objects in my application
right debugging is awesome I can figure
out flow control but understanding
what's going on there sometimes I need a
little bit more help so what I could do
is you know go on Stack Overflow or post
an issue in github but that could take
some time and since we're in a keynote
emmawho we should probably do things a
little bit faster so what I'm gonna do
is switch over to slack here and I've
got a colleague Amanda who is awesome at
JavaScript so I'm say hey Amanda I need
help
No and hopefully oops help now eleven
hopefully she's around alright she's
gonna be right there so at this point
what I could do is you know I could do a
screen sharing session with Amanda but
maybe there's stuff on my screen I don't
want to share this I've got email open
who knows what's in there and I don't
want to share that with her or you know
there's lots of Druid do it but really
if you look at the history of Visual
Studio in developer productivity
starting with intellisense and debugging
intellitrace and time travel debugging
we've really done a great job of sort of
advancing the productivity of developers
and what I want to do now is give you a
sneak preview a bit developer
productivity and what I'm going to do is
I'm gonna start a collaborative
development and debugging session with
Amanda who's remotely located so to do
that I'm gonna come down here I'm just
going to click on share and what this is
gonna do is it's gonna create a
connection to my workspace on my machine
that I can then share with Amanda
there's a link to it I'll go back over
to slack and I'm gonna paste this in and
now a man and I can start to work
together so what's awesome here is that
I can just copy this link and go to my
favorite code editing experience visual
studio and go to join X join
collaboration session now that's going
to pick up what's automatically on the
clipboard and I just click join and
what's happening here is that my visual
studio which is personalized for my use
so that I'm the most productive is
actually connecting remotely to Chris's
workspace which is hosted in the S code
and so what you see here is that we have
the solution Explorer quickly loaded
with all of his files I can expand web
util for example and look at some other
files here or I can go back to app J s
which is I think where he's editing and
I can actually see that yes in fact he
is headed in here we see as a cursor
right there there's Chris so Chris how
can I help you today we're probably on a
voice chat at this point so let me know
how can I help
all right so Amanda this loop seems to
be giving me a problem data dot tweets
comes in I've got lots of tweets and
sentiment data but I want to get down
here to the render method the sentiment
with level keeps coming back with a
bunch of undefined objects I have no
idea what's going on I was hoping maybe
you could help me out
so what's awesome is obviously as he's
describing the problem to me I'm
actually seeing it be highlighted in my
code editor so I know exactly what he's
talking about but further because this
is actually based on a connection that's
that has the all of the files that his
code depends on on his on his machine I
can actually do things that are based on
like semantic code navigation for
example so I can go to peak definition
look up the get happiness level and
actually look at what's going on there
so I get the full kind of navigation
experience that you would expect from
Visual Studio with this experience all
right Chris I I don't yet know what's
what the problem is can you reproduce it
for me
you bet so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to come over here to say line 19
I'm going to set a breakpoint and I come
down here and I'm going to share a
debugging session with Amanda and like
we saw before what will happen is node
will spin up on my machine she doesn't
have node installed on her machine I'll
go back over to the browser will refresh
the page and then what will happen is
we'll hit the breakpoint on my machine
and on her machine so what's awesome
about this is as Chris hits the
breakpoint on his machine Visual Studio
is actually also hitting the breakpoint
it's the same exact debug breakpoints
awesome awesome yeah
[Applause]
further Visual Studio actually goes into
a full debug mode so I have all of the
debug windows that you would expect from
Visual Studio when you are in a normal
debug session I have the locals window I
can kind of expand things look at data
etc look at the call stack but further
because we're actually sharing the debug
cursor I can even advance the debug
cursor by just going step over a couple
of times and we can step over it and I
can see here that s is actually zero
okay Chris at this point I know what the
problem is it's actually a rookie
JavaScript mistake
so why don't you stop debugging and I'll
let you know how you can never run into
this ever again all right let's fix that
rookie mistake I'll stop the bugger all
right I'm gonna go to the top of the
file and I'm just going to take
advantage of one of the features that's
my favorite aspect of the fact that
typescript is powering the JavaScript
language service which is that I can
actually use the typescript compiler as
a JavaScript linter so I can go ahead
and just write TS check here and even
though we're in a javascript file it's
actually using the typescript compiler
to do type checking on my JavaScript and
so what we see now is that I actually
have a typescript I mean a type checking
error which is that the property
sentiment doesn't exist on the types
type string so what happens here is that
you're actually you're going over an
array and if you use the let in
expression over an array then you go
over all of the enumerable properties of
the array object it's kind of a weird
JavaScript idiosyncrasy but if you use
let of so if I just go ahead and edit
this and change that to let of then
you'll actually see that the squizzle
should go away and everything's should
be fixed up so why don't you try it
again
awesome errors are gone on my screen as
well so all right let's let's see if
this works I'll press f5 again we'll
start up the the runtime in the debugger
I'll reload the page and once the site
comes up now I should be able to click
on one of the hotels see the sentiment
on the right and now my chart shows up
on the left
thank you very much Amanda I appreciate
that anytime Chris see you later all
right
stuff that debugging session all right
now that we've got our our front-end
application working let's go deploy this
thing to the cloud and to do that what
we're gonna do is use Azure app service
now as your app service is our fully
managed hosted web and API platform for
hosting our web applications what's
really cool about as your app services
you can run any sort of workload node
c-sharp dinette obviously but what I'm
excited about doing today is the fact
that you can actually bring your own
container to add your app service which
means you can run any type of web app on
our infrastructure you worry about your
application we'll worry about scaling it
and keeping it up and all that goodness
so let's go and do that right now so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
come to my darker file that's in my
application I'm just going to right
click on say build image and this is
contributed by that docker extension
that we installed earlier and that
creates the image we'll go over here to
our darker extension expand that a
little bit you can see that we've got
the image now in the machine web dot
latest that's what we just created I'm
gonna right-click on it and I'm gonna
tag it when I tag it I'm basically
giving it a name so it tells docker when
we do a push which is what we'll do
right now we'll docker push where to
push it to and by virtue of the fact
it's the SH 360 registry this is an
azure container registry a private Azure
container registry that I've got for my
application that I can use to put in
host images up in the cloud alright so
now that the image is now up in my
private registry I can go down in the
extension again drill into the registry
I can see the repository that we just
pushed to and there's the image so what
I'm gonna do you know if I want to
quickly try this out I'm just going to
right click and deploy the image to add
your app service it's gonna ask me a
couple of questions
what's the resource group which
basically defines the application up in
Azure it's gonna ask me what the plan is
and the plan is basically the machine
that it's going to run on you'll notice
just by virtue of the name but in
reality what it is it's a Linux machine
so it's gonna run our container on a
Linux machine in the azure app service
environment and now we just need to give
it a name that'll show up on the
internet say SH 360 web and we'll unique
fi it a little bit and we'll hit enter
so what's gonna happen now is on that
machine we're gonna go and provision
that web application it'll only take a
second to do and once it provisions the
web application we're gonna set some
properties on it we're gonna say hey
here is the image and the registry to go
pull from which is what we've done here
we restarted the site to sort of get it
going and now we've got a link to our
application hosted in the cloud and now
I can hold down alt click on that and
we're gonna browse to the site and
what's happening now is basically it's
doing a doc or pull on that machine and
pulling it down and then it'll load up
the container
run it and we should see our site here
in just one second
there we go there's our site running up
in the cloud we click on it we can see
we've got the fix for the application
that Amanda helped us out with earlier
so that's awesome that's kind of the
front end of the application we got that
deployed to the cloud let's go look at
what's going on on the back end of the
application now what we do in this app
is when tweets come in we basically pull
them off the wire and we persist them in
Azure cosmos TV now Azure cosmos DB is
our fully managed globally distributed
highly scalable no sequel database in
the cloud and what we do is we come in
and we pulled them into a document
database and using the cosmos DB
extension I can drill down in here
there's my tweets database my tweets
collection and here are all the tweets
that we've collected over time you can
see kudos to Platinum Hotel things like
that so this is how we can and you know
store our data in cosmos is a great
solution for this problem because as
more hotels come online worldwide
cosmos will provide me turnkey data
replication
worldwide just by clicking a couple
check boxes guaranteed throughput and
very very fast or low latency so it's
going to scale with my application but
not only do we sort of pull the tweets
and we do some analysis and processing
on these tweets once we get them and to
do that we actually use a service as
your function and a service as your
function is perfect for this scenario as
well because whether I'm getting one
tweet or a million tweets the function
will scale up scale down and I only end
up paying for the compute processing
that I used to do that so let's go see
what that looks like I'm going to come
back up to my Explorer
I'm gonna right-click and say add folder
to workspace and this is one of the new
features of Visual Studio code that just
released and stable a couple of days ago
and I'm gonna add this to the workspace
and this is something we call multi root
workspace workspaces so now what we have
is two top level folders that we can
work with together in one sort of group
and this is the function that runs
whenever tweet comes in so I'm gonna do
is come in here to index J s and this is
what happens you know we get the tweet
in we analyze the tweets we calm at
Microsoft the azure cognitive services
and use text analytics to analyze the
text to generate the sentiment and then
we go and we save it back off to a graph
in cosmos TV now functions are awesome
because they run up in the cloud and
they scale out and everything but
they're also difficult to sort of debug
but with Azure service functions what we
can do is actually run them and debug
them locally on our machine so what I
can do just like we did with our app
running locally I can come in here I'll
put a breakpoint on line 11 I'm gonna go
to my debug view and because we're in
multi route mode right now I can pick
the target that will load up the
function and press play and what's gonna
happen at this point is we're gonna load
the azure runtime function runtime on my
machine this is the same runtime
oops one time that runs up in the cloud
and what happens is whenever someone
tweets about it data changes in the
cloud but we break in our function
locally on our machine and so I said
whoops because somebody already tweeted
about it and we broke on our on our
function but we can have a little bit
more fun with that so I'll press play
and so what I need everybody to do right
now is take out your phones and tweet
I love pound smart hotel 360 and what
will happen is once you do that we will
hit the break point boom so somebody
tweeted about it thank you very much and
then we can sort of step and do all the
great debugging experiences that we saw
earlier but again this is all triggered
off data that's changing up in the cloud
debugging locally on my machine so what
we can do now once we're done with that
we can come back over to our workspace I
could right click and then using the the
azure function application I can deploy
this up to the cloud that I'm happy to
work with it and so what we've seen here
this morning is a great lightweight code
editor we've seen hosting and publishing
of docker images to the cloud we've seen
a collaborative development and
debugging experience we've seen planet
scalable data access and we've seen
functions that can run locally and in
the cloud it really is a great time to
be a developer thank you very much
[Applause]